il vit aux appartements la chapelle
depuis huit ans mais début février alex
a appris qu'il était évincé de son
appartement le 15 mars d'être mis à la
rue comme ça dans une semaine c'est
normal dans une vie d'une vie un pays
normal vous pensera que ce sera et
légale du juste dans l'ain six semaines
du habits 35 personnes qui comme alex
vivent avec un problème de santé mentale
et qui sont encadrés par un organisme
communautaire tout le monde ici a un
problème mental dans la santé mentale
et m
alors c'était c'était bien d'être dans
un endroit édifice qui ferment supervisé
avec l'assistance de laizy de valeur
mais le propriétaire ne veut pas
prolonger l'entente avec le réseau de la
santé qui arrive à terme le bâtiment est
à vendre et le prix sera très élevé de
christophe est actuellement
très faible or si on ne demande que
pour les organismes qui veulent
maintenir la vocation abordable de
certains édifices la mission est quasi
impossible
posté en pole elle la peau site et de
faire des dépôts pis de faire des offres
d'acheteurs agressé dans le marché donc
non actuellement cc dix crans au centre
et des savoirs à bout logements
abordables même problème pour la
construction neuve dont les coûts
explosent nous inquiéter des projets le
cris ou simplement maintenir des
logements abordables exige une
intervention de l'état différentes
mesures facilitant comme des garanties
très d assurance hypothécaire à faible
coût ou encore des prêts à faible taux
d'intérêt
mais également des contributions non
remboursables à l'étagé au dessus on
rencontre un autre résident qui sera
évincé des appartements la chapelle
jean natte npd j'hésite à être ici
depuis six ans déménager sera pour lui
plutôt difficile
au moins il a une alternative ailleurs
parce que trouver un hébergement santé
mentale reste compliqué on compte 3000
places d'hébergement en santé mentale
sur l'île de montréal et 604 personnes
en attente la pénurie touche d'autres
régions comme l'outaouais laval et
chaudière appalaches et frappe des gens
vulnérables comme tous nos fans
je n'ai jamais vraiment vécu seul dit il
ce qu'il cas de plusieurs des 35
résidents je ne suis pas certaine que
les gens vont être capables de trouver
un autre endroit l'établissement de
santé affirme avoir finalement réussi à
re localiser les résidents avant leur
expulsion le 15 mars mais c'est clair le
marché immobilier québécois qui était en
ébullition laisse de moins en moins de
place aux gens vulnérables comme alex
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal